and joining me here on the rich eisen
show big fan of this man's work
in better call saul and breaking bad his
new film
is nobody in which he plays somebody who
looks like a nobody but is anything but
he is bob odenkirk how are you bob
great rich how are you i am better for
talking to you
so um let's let's get into a whole bunch
of good stuff with you bob
um let's start let's start with the
sports let's start with the chicago cubs
that is your team correct
that is your journey i was going to ask
you to that's
the last thing i was going to say tell
me about the cubs i mean i know
schwarber's gone and there's a lot of
trading in and out
and i'm sad to see people leave who i've
gotten to know
over the last few years but um
here's how it works with me in sports
okay my wife hates sports
oh gosh she hates him so much
that she told me once just so you know
i won't go into a room if you have
sports on
in that room oh my gosh bob
if you have sports on the tv i won't
walk into that room
so has she never been to wrigley field
then she's never had
she went she okay she had a great time
because that'll that'll that'll change
that'll change any
that'll that'll ruin everybody's won't
that win anybody over i mean come on
wrigley is the greatest place in the
world
i can't wait to get back there and sit
there and watch a game and and just take
it in it's just the best i used to live
about
well i lived about six or seven blocks
from there right down the street
and i worked at cozy's bike shop on uh
clark uh clark or halsted and uh
halsted and i you know used to go to the
afternoon games because it's the best
like seven dollars for bleacher seat and
it was
you know all these games that started at
one
and nobody could go to him you know and
uh you just wander over there and buy a
ticket
and watch the game do you have a harry
carrie story do you ever run into him do
you ever meet him anything about that
when i was uh
a little kid um my grandfather grew up
my grandfather
grew up four blocks from kaminsky old
kaminsky okay place
and uh so he was a sox fan when he was
young and we went
and harry was still at the sox remember
harry was yeah
he was a he was a he was he was a south
side a voice before he was synonymous
and we stand right underneath his booth
and he would drop down the net
with the programs and pick up the
programs and sign them and then drop
them back
down i mean i never met harry but
i from when i was a kid like nine years
old
he was a big part of my world
um just uh to have seen him there
because we sat right under the booth
on uh one of the games we went to and
then uh
and then i don't know if my grandfather
became a cubs fan because harry moved
to the cubs that might make sense that
might so so who was i guess your cub
growing up
who was the guy that uh um was it andre
dawson could have been ryan sandberg one
of those guys
back in the town i met ernie banks how
cool is that
you know ernie banks ernie banks is one
of the greatest human beings of all time
i remember i was
dating my my uh now wife
and we were we were on a uh a golf range
bob
and hitting golf balls in phoenix you
know i don't know why
and then ernie banks was there and i'd
met him at an espy's awards
and he came up he asked us you know if
we were going to have
babies together if we're gonna get
married we were just dating at the time
yeah and i'm like you know what uh ernie
i don't know if we're gonna play too
like that
but uh he was just telling us about the
beauty of family and
being you know being in love and he was
just a human being it was just the
greatest thing ever bob
he signed baseballs at the little local
bank in naperville where i grew up
and i don't know who took me there but i
waited in line
and got his autograph on a ball and
i also like fergie jenkins i don't know
why fergie
okay there you go he was just won a ton
of baseball games for the cubs
but it's the best great yeah that's cool
bob odenkirk here
on the rich eisen show let's get into
your film here nobody
um and what did you like about it i'm
sure again
you get a lot of scripts in front of you
and you get to pick and choose what you
want what you want to do
what do you got for you and rich the the
movie came from me
it was my idea okay so walk me through
it
well it's there's a lot of uh reasons
why i
pursued it but um i was here
shooting better call saul and it this
show plays around the world and
i my brother-in-law luke sent me a
screen grab of an ad for the show
in china and i thought holy crap they're
watching me in china
what kind of movie could i make that
could play because i knew this show
played in russia and
italy and uh well action movies play
around the world and i started thinking
about the character from better call
saul who's like a striving guy
who fails and never quits and he's
earnest it's a kind of
you know he's a very funny character at
times but there's a lot of times when
he's on screen and he's utterly earnest
and
not ironic at all and his heart is on
his sleeve
and i thought that's an action character
except that he doesn't fight but
otherwise
that's an action character so if i'm
willing to learn to fight which i am
[Music]
uh it'll take years to get a movie made
and i have years
uh and then i started thinking about a
story and a character
you know i've had two break-ins in my
home
uh very disturbing to my family left me
with a lot of
uh feelings uh that are expressed in
this movie
nobody um a lot of what you see in the
first few minutes it's from my life
which is so weird because it's a total
genre movie and it goes into
fantastic realms it's written by derek
colstad but the
the nugget the initial idea of what
drives the character and the
sort of intense feelings of frustration
and rage are from my life and and
include
including that break-in and including
when
the one have you seen the movie have i
seen the movie yet i have not sir
i got the link last night and as you
know i've got three small children
in the first one yeah well don't let
them walk in on you watching this movie
okay sounds good they'll have nightmares
uh this is not for kids um
and the and somebody holds a gun up to
me and they want my wedding ring and i
won't give it to them
that's actually from an incident in my
life as well when i got held
up in chicago and they told me to
do something and i said no and
so this little nugget of the character
and where it begins is all from me and
then the where the story goes is all
derek colstad so
i i had this idea and i had this idea
that i could
unlike a lot of times when you see the
trope of of the guy who's a nobody and
he's gonna fight
you know and he's gonna surprise you all
with his skills it's often played by an
action star and you go well i know he
can kick ass i've seen him kick ass in
20 films already i don't for a second
believe that
he's unsure of himself or this might not
turn out the way he wants it to
you know i thought i could actually
bring that to the screen
because nobody thinks i could do
anything and i doubt it myself
and i would and also rich when if you do
see the film i will i really
i really wanted to put that in my
character's eyes
this feeling of i don't know
if i can do what i'm setting out to do
um he doubts himself and so these were
things i thought i could bring to this
genre this is a genre movie
if you like action movies i hope you'll
love it i wanted to make
people who love this type of film happy
um because i'm a bit of an interloper
well you as i told you when i've met you
personally i'm a
huge fan of everything that you do and
nobody is in theaters right now
and it's available on premium video on
demand
on april 16th and you have been in some
remarkably
iconic pieces of uh television for sure
from breaking bad and better call saul
the larry sanders show bob
uh to me was so far ahead of its time
yeah and so remarkable what was it like
to be on the set
of that show bob uh well
gary shandling you know
was everything the spirit of the show
the mind of the show
the work ethic of the show was gary
shandling i mean it was
i think one of the reasons he didn't do
too much after that
and not much in tv at all um
was because he kind of did did it
did it exactly the way he wanted and it
worked out the way he wanted
and what more is there to prove sort of
but
um you know it was a fun set
uh except for gary but
when he was just uh it was uh
gary was very serious and sweated
every line and every choice to a degree
that made me feel a little sorry for him
no kidding i wished he could have
enjoyed his achievement more
but he was trying to achieve it as we
were
doing and he was trying to make it
perfect and i'm
there's no such thing as perfect uh
except
sometimes you get lucky with an outcome
and everything comes together but
you can't be perfect you can only be the
best that you can be
every day and uh but he was aiming for
perfection and he got pretty damn close
and it's really a special and unique
show that
is dramatic and funny and deep and
shallow it's everything it is and
you were great in it the cast was
remarkable and every single time that i
wa
anytime i watch one i have to drop the
remote to the end
it's just it is just so much fun to
watch and it's such a
piece of you know uh history of
television that you know you were part
of there and then
obviously saul goodman comes your way
and now
jimmy mcgill about to become saul
goodman or has just become
saul goodman you're in albuquerque right
now
shooting the final episodes uh of this
character
yeah i know this is fight club type
stuff you can't talk about it but what
can you possibly tell me about this
final season of better call cell you're
shooting right now
i can tell you that um you know our show
has been a slow burn and for some people
extremely slow
but uh similar to breaking bad
but i think to a greater degree that
vince gilligan and peter gould and the
writing staff
set up all these dominoes you know and
now they're just
they just are knocking them down as we
go into our final season big
things are happening constantly and it
really is blowing my mind and making me
very happy and very excited
because uh i want to give the audience
that reward
and also i
i empathize and i like my character but
i want him to
uh
get his ass kicked
[Laughter]
and come out a better person a different
person
i just want him to feel the
pressure all the way and and just crack
and become something else and and that's
what they're doing and they're doing it
with all the characters not just
saul not just jimmy mcgill and uh
yeah so get ready man it's good i can't
really i cannot wait so do you know how
it ends right now or is that no
i don't i have only read the first four
okay
so when you get like when you get the
script you must be
not only obviously i get to read it like
a fan and
uh i could read all of them but they
have them but i
just choose to go one at a time
as we work on them and uh
i'd rather i mean it's like
i can't wait to see what happens next
and it's always surprising
and it always makes emotional sense it's
crazy what they do
it is it is great and like i said you're
terrific in it the second to last
episode of last season was as close to a
breaking bad episode as i think better
call saul got where you were stuck
uh in the desert with mike herman trout
and uh
needing to uh consume your own uh
fluids uh to actually survive uh i'm
assuming that was gatorade what was that
what was that in the in the bottle
it was uh some it was i wish it was
gatorade
well i don't know it was not urine
i it was um you know fake urine like you
get at the grocery store
like you get at the white sox games not
at the wrigley game
in bulk don't you costco they have fake
urine just go to the back aisle
fantastic well uh as you matriculate
your way through that show and
um you know want to talk about it i'd
love to have you back on the show and i
i look forward for everybody to seeing
nobody which is again in theaters right
now uh
and available on premium video on demand
on april 16th with bob odenkirk
great to see you bob thank you for the
time you're rich thanks you guys that's
bob odenkirk right here on the rich
eisen show
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here